à l'occasion de la saison france
portugal cette année le ccco d accueil
une toute nouvelle exposition sur les
enjeux du xxème siècle portugais 40
femmes artistes présentent leurs
créations à découvrir jusqu en septembre
2022 regardez c'est avec théodore de
queiros
l'exposition commence par cet
autoportrait d'aurélia des souza un
regard frontale qui défie les
conventions du siècle passé
le ton est donné ici ce sont les femmes
qui posent leur regard sur l'histoire et
plus particulièrement celle du portugal
dans cette exposition on déambule entre
les enjeux du siècle dernier au fil d'un
parcours chrono thématique des
constructions des rapports entre l'homme
et la femme à celui du corps ou de la
sexualité on monte ensuite dans les
étages comme dans le temps est alors
abordée l'enjeu coloniale du portugal
plus loin une artiste aborde celui de la
chute du régime salazariste en 1974
les thématiques se modernise au fil des
salles dans la suivante il est question
de notre domination sur la nature et si
c'est qu'on voit c'est
c'est la german géométrisation
aucune gêne à
finalement c'est toute la complexité du
xxème siècle portugais qui est projetée
sur les murs du centre olivier debré
l'histoire des construite par 40 femmes
et ces femmes elle s'affirme par un
regard sur elle même et sur le monde et
c'est vraiment propositions politiques
comme un geste de réparation de
l'effacement de la femme depuis des
siècles et des siècles un message fort
qui se condense en une seule phrase tout
ce que je veux le titre rend hommage à
ces femmes du siècle dernier qui ne
demandait qu'à quitter leur statut de
muse pour accéder à celui d'artiste